And you know you'll need to provide multiple copies of
this image, so low pixel count devices can save bandwidth
or high pixel count devices can get a crisp image.
It's possible to do this on the server side in some
cases. In fact, some content systems let you simply specify
what size you want a given source image app And they
deal with the trans coding on the server end including
caching. If you want the images to actually represent different art,
different crops for example you'll have to do
that manually. For each of these images though you
should remember to tune the quality parameters to
minimize file size while maximizing quality. You'll need at
least 1x and 2x versions of your images
although 1.3x and 3x are fairly common too now.
Again, note that although I'm speaking of this as
1x or 2x, for purposes of device pixel ratio,
for responsive images, you may request different images based
on available layout width. You may even want to
change the image itself. For example, in Landscape mode,
I may want to crop the picture completely differently.